من كل ذنب فان كانت المعصيه بين العبد
وبين الله تعالى لا تتعلق بحق ادمي فلها
ثلاثه شروط
النووي رحمه الله
الصالحين
‏tell us that repentance isation
is binding upon everyone from every sin
from each sin
hence if
the sin being repented from
is between
the servant and between
and
does
‏another
person
احدها
ان يقلع عن المعصيه
which is being repented from
ان يندم على فعلها
the second is the
والثالث ان يعزم الا يعود اليها ابدا
neverان
فقد احد الثلاثه لم تصح توبته
‏any
وان كانت المعصيه تتعلق بادمي فشروطها
اربعه هذه الثلاثه
وان يبرا من حق صاحبها
if being repented
‏of another being
repentance from such a sin has four
these three affirmed
the three affirmed conditions
من حق صاحبها and that the person
return or make
فان كانت مالا او نحوه رده
‏if
some kind of monetary value that the
person
unrifully taken from another
is
whoever
they have taken it from
حدفوه
مكنه منه او طلب عفوه andves another
person's character or another person's
reputation
then in order to repent a person must
admit to their wronging and seek
forgiveness from the person that they
have wrongedutation
وان كانت غيبه استحله منه and if
قذف قذف
القذف الشرعي او القذف
العرفي او اللغوي
‏accuses anotheruly
this is not only ma sin but this is
veryathing to a person's reputation
so the person must give them up and
they must admit to that or if it is
which is back bting speaking
ويجب ان يتوب من جميع الذنوب
فان تاب من بعضها صحت توبته عند اهل الحق
من ذلك الذنب وبقي عليه الباقي
‏And if toent
from sin and not a holistic repentance
their repentance is accept with to what
they have repent from and whatever they
have not repented from ising upon them
and they are considered
responsible for
وقد تظاهر دلائل الكتاب والسنه واجماع
الامه على وجوب التوبه
قران
ofentation
[Silence]
‏and sched
upon
repentance
andidences
from theران and are to numous to mention
in one specific place he قال الله تعالى
وتوبوا الى الله جميعا ايها المؤمنون
لعلكم
لعلكم تفلحون
سوره النور number 31 الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
وقال تعالى استغفروا ربكم ثم توبوا اليه
سه number
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز وقال تعالى يا
ايها الذين امنوا توبوا الى الله توبه
نصوحه من سوره التحريم نمبر 8 الله سبحانه
وتعالى
الله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين جزاكم الله خيرا